-Well, guys the big news,
of course,
is that the president
and first lady
have tested positive
for coronavirus.
In any other time in history,
this would be the craziest story
of all time.
In the year 2020, it's Friday.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously when the news broke,
2020 was like,
"Come on, you had to see
this one coming."
[ Laughter ]
I actually didn't
see this coming.
Last night, I went to bed
thinking tonight's
whole monologue would be about
NASA calling off their mission
to send a $23 million toilet
to space.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-We had 300 jokes on that.
-[ Groans ]
-Unlike the presidential debate,
I hope people can learn
from this.
If the most powerful, most
protected person on Earth
can get COVID-19, anyone can.
And no one should have to suffer
through this horrible virus.
But, yeah,
in the middle of night,
Trump confirmed the test results
by tweeting...
He tweeted that around 1:00 a.m.
Usually,
that'd make people panic,
but for Trump, that actually
shows he's feeling normal.
[ Light laughter ]
Once the news broke,
tons of well wishes poured in
from leaders around the country.
Some Democrats even meant them.
[ Laughter ]
Joe Biden tweeted...
Trump was so touched.
He was like, "That's sweet.
Give him a like,
but not a retweet."
[ Light laughter ]
Of course, support for the
president and the first lady
is also coming in
from around the world.
-Russia's Vladimir Putin
wished President Trump well
in a telegram according
to Russian state media.
...the telegram reportedly said.
-Wait, a telegram?
[ Laughter ]
-Right?
-What happened? Was the
messenger pigeon in the shop?
[ Laughter ]
Putin was like
[ Russian accent ] Sorry,
is closest thing we have
to email.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
It wasn't just a telegram.
Putin also sent Trump a get-well
Edible Arrangement.
Of course, in Russia,
Edible Arrangements
are filled with rocks
and expired beets.
[ Laughter ]
All this information
came out last night,
but it wasn't the White House
that broke the news.
Listen to this.
-It was not the White House that
informed the American public
or informed us reporters
that Hope Hicks had reported
positive for this virus.
It was Jen Jacobs, a reporter
at Bloomberg News.
-Actually,
Bob Woodward also knew,
but he was saving the story
for his next book
in eight months.
[ Laughter ]
When it comes to keeping
secrets, the White House
is worse than the "Big Brother"
house.
Luckily, some people in Trump's
inner circle are okay.
-Vice President Pence and
the Second Lady, Karen Pence,
have tested negative
this morning.
That's according
to their press secretary.
Obviously they were
quite concerned.
-That's right,
Mike Pence got tested.
For the nurse, it was like
sticking a cotton swab
up a giant cotton swab.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it was a roller coaster
of a day for Pence.
Here he is when he found out he
might have been exposed
to the virus.
And here he is celebrating
that he is completely fine.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile all this news is
leading to questions
about the next presidential
debate.
-Will the next presidential
debate even happen?
It is supposed to be in 13 days.
If you've tested positive
for COVID,
you are supposed to isolate
at least 10 days
after the symptoms first appear.
-Yep, the debate
could be postponed --
not 'cause of the coronavirus,
just 'cause no one
wants to moderate it.
[ Laughter ]
Mitch McConnell
even floated the idea
of holding a virtual debate.
That should be good.
They couldn't stop interrupting
each other in person, and now
they're gonna try it over Zoom?
[ Laughter ]
Can we leave the meeting?
Let's change gears here.
Today, I saw that a New York
staple is returning tomorrow
after a six-month absence...
-Horse-drawn carriages
are returning to Central Park
on Saturday.
Carriage drivers held a news
conference in the park.
Rides were halted in March
when nonessential businesses
were closed.
-Good news is everyone agrees
that masks are good
when you are sitting
right behind a horse.
[ Laughter ]
New York is a lot different
than it was six months ago.
For 50 bucks, you can
hitch a ride around a park
or buy a two-bedroom apartment.
[ Laughter, groaning ]
It's been a weird time
for the horses, too,
because the past six months,
they've been working over Zoom.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, I saw that Brach's
is now selling candy corn
that tastes like
Thanksgiving dinner
with flavors like green bean,
turkey, and stuffing.
[ People groaning ]
Hey, don't knock it
until you spit it out.
[ Laughter ]
If that was the vaccine for
coronavirus,
people still wouldn't eat them.
[ Laughter ]
At this point, 2020 is just
rubbing it in.